well the former girlfriend of NFL star
LeSean McCoy says she is convinced he
was involved in her assault and attacked
by a masked intruder left
delecia accord own bloodied and bruised
last week her attorney says she was
pistol-whipped and the attacker stole
two Cartier bracelets CBS this morning
Saturday co-host Dana Jacobson spoke
with the attorney Jane a good morning
good morning core tone is being
represented by attorney Tanya Mitchell
Graham she says her client has now moved
out of the suburban Atlanta house where
she was attacked but remains traumatized
the bruising and swelling on her face
still visible had it ever been violent
between them no did she ever fear him I
don't get that impression but she's
never been attacked before either is she
afraid of
LeSean McCoy now I think she is now she
is on edge and she is very much afraid
attorney Tanya Mitchell Graham says
Delicia cordons attacker wanted the same
expensive jewelry she says her
ex-boyfriend has been demanding she give
back like I'm dreaming right now
when LeSean McCoy gave them to cord
owned in 2016 for her birthday she
posted about it on her Instagram account
is she open to the possibility that it
was public knowledge that she had all
this jewelry on the premises when she
said to this person
hey it's I don't have it it's in a safe
deposit box he accepted that I'm not
certain what type of burglar would
accept something like that the intruder
also didn't force his way in according
to graham mccoy had the home security
system changed about a month before the
attack and Corden wasn't given the code
to arm it the Buffalo Bills running back
calls the claims against him totally
baseless saying I have not had any
direct contact with any of the people
involved in months so does he have any
indirect involvement that's the question
that needs to be answered actually do
you believe mr. McCoy is tied to this
I'm not certain what I see is a lot of
circumstantial evidence but if she
believes that LeSean McCoy is tied to it
but police can never prove that will she
be
okay as long as the person that hurt her
is put away I can't really answer that
one for her because she absolutely
believes mr. McCoy had something to do
with this LeSean McCoy is attorney Don
Samuel says his client does not have the
ability to access the security footage
from the house he also tells CBS this
morning he has spoken briefly with
investigators
he didn't say whether McCoy himself has
done so right I'm sure that
investigation continues Thank You Dana